it is great to be joined today by Karen
Presley who spent two decades as a
celebrity recruiter for Scientology and
was a member of the Sea Org which we
have spoken about before she escaped the
church three times most recently in 1998
her memoir is escaping Scientology an
insider's true story
so Karen it's it's great to have you on
I guess to start with how did you first
get involved with Scientology because I
know you know we've spoken to many
former Scientologists some
second-generation some chose to choosing
to get involved themselves as adults
what was your scenario well my husband
at the time Peters les and I moved to LA
and around 1980 and basically we heard
about Scientology through other
musicians and artists and designers in
LA a lot of people that we met were
already Scientologists or talked about
Scientology Chick Corea
John Travolta those are just some of the
people that you know influenced us and
did it ever appeal to you as for the
actual religious beliefs or was it more
something that was a community of sorts
for you
you know honestly the attraction at
first was community because we were
brand-new to LA it's a very competitive
environment and the celebrity Center
building and the people that work there
with pretty much love bomb you and make
you feel very safe as if it was a refuge
a place of safety and also you know not
so much the religion but more the
self-help aspect of it appealed to us
that's interesting so as you became more
involved in it was there a way in which
it sort of actually felt like if you
were to know if this weren't a part of
your life that you would sort of be
materially worse off absolutely that's a
great question because it really didn't
take too long for us to get to that
mindset
the celebrity Center has particular
techniques and policies that they use
written by l ron Hubbard and all the
staff are very focused on how to
indoctrinate the new people into the
system and once you get into that and
you're not aware of the indoctrination
it's very gradual and it's very light at
first but really what's going on is you
become radicalized by Scientology and
you you fail to notice that you're
gradually and slowly replacing your
original values morals and belief with
those that are embedded into you by the
Scientologists so Cynthia its
around-the-clock procedure you know
you're you're never really allowed to be
gone other than going to work going home
to sleep but you have to be there every
day
you're noticed if you don't attend the
event so it's like everything about it
indoctrinates you into the mindset can
you give us an example of a value that
you could point to where you held it
before you started working your way up
through the ranks it's in Scientology
and how it changed like I think it would
be interesting to hear an example of
what you mean by that
several let's talk valuing a family you
know when you when you grow up with as I
did I grew up in Chicago with a huge
family of relatives cousins aunts uncles
grandparents mom and dad sisters and
brothers and it was definitely a strong
family but we had strong family values
where family was to be protected and
defended and loved and when we got into
Scientology the value that really was
compromised was that family value of it
became okay to start pushing your family
in your other friends who are not
Scientologists out of your life because
sign
takes precedence over everything and the
main thing that became important to us
was not our career not our family and
not our outside friends but Scientology
and clearing the planet and
Scientologists goals
so those things absolutely did replace
our original values and beliefs there's
this very fan we'll get to it of course
as you're when you became part of the
Sea Org but there's this very like
authoritarian nature to the structure
and I find it interesting that there's
the similarity when we talk about how
authoritarianism sort of appears in
political systems
it doesn't appear overnight it's
starting to attack some of the
institutions that are part of democracy
whether it's independent press or the
judicial system or whatever the case may
be and if on day one you were told this
is where we're eventually going to be it
would seem inconceivable because it
would be such a drastic change is it
true that in these cult-like scenarios
it's a similar dynamic where if on day
one they said listen an X number of
years here's what you're going to be
accepting you would say there's no way
that I would allow myself to be involved
in that but because it sort of creeps in
your defenses are slowly disarmed that
is a great way to describe it your
defenses are gradually slowly disarmed
because your mindset you become so
vulnerable to the policies and the
teachings of l ron Hubbard that you grow
to believe that clearing the planet
through Scientology takes precedence
over everything over sleeping over your
personal health over your relationship
with your spouse over friendships and
family like I said so but that's part of
the radicalization of Scientology and we
went through that at the celebrity
Center but during the first couple years
of being a Scientologist but it it by
the time we transit the church
headquarters which is the Internet
management base where it was like moving
from Earth to Mars in terms of heavy
indoctrination the Sea Org viewpoint
which reigned over everything that was
that took precedent over your mind it's
like you had to be the Sea Org member to
clear the planet but not only that you
had to support command intention which
is the leader David Miscavige issuing
orders that compromised with your own
sense of logic and rationality and
putting yourself at risk to achieve the
goals and to complete his orders so as
to please him and that's where the
cult-like behavior just absolutely
proves itself that this organization is
a cult rich versus church you escaped in
1990 and you escaped again in 1993 and
then you after the second escape stayed
another five years before leaving for
the final time in 1998 if I have the
dates correct
talk first about well there's so many
ways we could go I mean maybe maybe you
can briefly just tell us why the word
escape is so often used in other words
why is it just not leaving or quitting
first of all but secondly what was the
sort of catalyst for you saying the
first time I need out and then
ultimately for when you made that
decision more permanently what was it
that had changed in your perspective
about it that made you say this this
can't be for me anymore oh that's that's
a long answer but I have actually
covered that in my book in depth but
let's talk about escape your once you're
in the Sea Org particularly in a cultic
headquarter like the in base was you
can't just leave you can't say I changed
my mind sorry it's time for me to go I'm
going to go rejoin my family you cannot
do that you do not have your own
mobility or autonomy you can't leave
without permission from numerous people
you have to complete a security check or
interrogation in order to even leave the
out of the gates of the property those
are just a couple things so you can't
just say I've changed my mind I'm
leaving sorry you have to escape you you
have to take it upon yourself to break
out during when there is like in my case
I timed my first escape by when I knew
there was a very small window when there
was no security and or security was less
intense and I was able to drive out of
the gates with without being apprehended
so that's that that's what I mean by
escape some people hid in trunks of cars
some people climbed over fences and tore
up their legs on the barbed wire that
was atop the chain-link fence and
security teams raced after them on
motorcycles to capture them and bring
them back so it's truly an escape and
that is no joke
that's not a movie scene that's reality
in terms of changing my mind or what was
the catalyst that caused me to finally
break out well the first time which was
like you said 1990 I I became intolerant
of the physical abuse the sleep
deprivation being treated like I was a
slave and I just refused to put up with
it nice book with my husband about it
but he didn't agree and I wanted him to
leave with me so I had to escape without
him but I came back because I didn't
want our marriage to end like you said I
escaped a second time in 1993 came back
for the same reason stayed five more
years and when I came when I broke what
had happened is you know you pile so
many things on a shelf in your mind of
things that you're unhappy about or you
don't want to tolerate but you put them
aside because you try to quote a quote
in the words of the Sea Org make it go
right and then you try to toe the line
you need the approval of the powers that
be so you behave in such a way that
doesn't
you in trouble but the the conditions
became so intolerable to my own personal
values and conscience and my moral
compass broke I realized that I had to
get out in order to survive because I
was not going to survive if I stayed and
and that it took me five years this the
third time to get to that point where I
finally broke and that is what made me
willing to have to go through anything
just to get out are people ever
irredeemable in the eyes of Scientology
I mean certainly you know you left
initially and you were allowed back and
then you left a second time and you were
allowed back and we've talked to Lori
Hudson about this as well and how she
had to go through this process of sort
of recanting all of the things that she
did and said when when she had left is
there ever a point in Scientology where
someone is irredeemable or is there
always an opportunity to come back if
you do the right thing good question
they have a program called the
rehabilitation project force which is
basically in essence a prison camp and
they end you they tell you that you are
irredeemable you you can't be you know
you can't function along with the rest
of the ethical Sea Org members so you
get dumped into the prison camp and you
have to go through 24/7 365 days a year
until you finish some people are there
for years before they quote-unquote
complete their program but what that
program completion really is is you have
become so broken and you have become so
bottom doubt as an individual you've
taken on the mindset of the leadership
and you believe that you basically scum
unless you're a perfect Sea Org member
so you put aside your own personal again
values content and then a winning
personality of a sirak member and that
is when you're redeemable that's when
you're allowed to rejoin the group last
thing I want to touch on and we do have
pretty limited time left is
how do you recruit celebrities when you
are part of the celebrity Center like
what's the strategy our celebrities ever
targeted unless you know that they
already have an interest maybe or have
friends that are part of Scientology how
is that how does that process go well
first of all there's a policy in that
Ellen Hubbard wrote about recruiting raw
meat and it's a absolute targeted
strategy for people who are currently
celebrity Scientologists to list the
names of all the people that they know
and work with and they meet with the
president of Celebrity Center and they
strategize how they're going to get to
those people and I mean we used to plant
when I was in celebrity recruitment we
used to intentionally send people to
certain parties and Hollywood because we
knew certain people were going to be
there and we had strategies to invite
these people to lunch or go out for a
drink or whatever
it's absolutely strategized how we
recruited celebrities my husband and I
at the time were I was a designer and he
was a musician so we spoke to everybody
we knew from Jeffrey Osborne to share to
Randy Jackson to loads of Frank Stallone
loads of people and musicians in Santana
and we did get quite a few people in but
none of them actually stayed except one
and and who was who was the one that
stayed oh she was a wife of Greg Rowley
who was a musician in Santana
her name was Garnett and she stayed for
many many years but everybody else that
we got in like Frank Stallone he tried
it and left
Michael caravello from Santana trying to
in love and a lot of you have been
speaking with Karen Presley who spent
two decades as a celebrity recruiter for
Scientology her memoir is called
escaping Scientology an insider's true
story Karen thank you so much for
talking to us today thank you so much
for having me